[Music]
hi everybody welcome to the data science
hangout if you're joining for the first
time i'm rachel it's great to meet you
if this is your first hangout this is an
open space for the whole data science
community to connect and chat about data
science leadership
questions you're facing and what's going
on in the world of data science
so we always want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
there's three ways that you can ask
questions
you can jump in live and raise your hand
on zoom seems to work well you could put
questions in the zoom chat and feel free
to just put a little star next to it if
you want me to read it or i could
call on you to introduce yourself and
add some context there too
we also have a slido link that tyler
will share in just a second here where
you can ask questions anonymously too
she's ahead of me i see it
i just like to reiterate that we love to
hear from everyone no matter your level
of experience or area of work as well
but today i'm so happy to be joined by
my co-host for today tegan bansu ashby
tegan is a senior software developer at
the brooklyn nets and also co-founder of
women in sports data
and tegan i'd love to start off by maybe
having you introduce yourself and share
a bit about your work
oh well
we're so secretive like there's a
there's a joke about how the brooklyn
nets are kind of like the kremlin but
you know second rate but at a high level
my job is to help win basketball games
and i do that by translating data into
applications and insights and
recommendations
for how everybody within the brooklyn
nets makes basketball related decisions
so in front office so how we evaluate
players for draft acquisition or trade
um to the coaching staff of how do we
best strategize how to defend a
pick-and-roll
awesome can i ask you what's something
that you're really excited about
in regards to data lately
uh like data in basketball or data in
general yeah data science in general or
data in basketball whatever's most
exciting to you
um i'm really excited about computer
vision in
in
like broadcast technology i don't know
if that's a so i'm a software engineer
and so really more data science adjacent
um
but
yeah something that that we really
struggle with is
getting uh
rich enough data sets on
college players or basically players who
aren't
um on an nba court because one of the
primary data sets that we use uh comes
from cameras in every um nba
stadium that tracks the the player
location
um
is tied with events but we don't have
that for uh for our draft and something
that would be really really useful would
be able to have that
um
from from television but it's such a
hard problem because you know the frames
are
jumpy um sometimes like
cv confuses like players on the on the
wrong team
things like that but having that would
be immensely immensely exciting
cool as we're waiting for everyone to
jump in with their questions too i i'd
love to hear a little bit more about
women and sports data and how you
started that too
sure um
so women in sports data is kind of this
ground swell event that a couple of my
fellow amazing women in sports data
from his nasho sargalis and dianna moa
who was a data scientist at the los
angeles lakers
we just really felt that we needed a
space where
we could
kind of showcase
our abilities
and have a platform to talk in a real
technical manner about how data is
applied to sport
um
and just to have that opportunity so i'm
really fortunate that the brooklyn nets
you know i came to rgm with this idea of
like
we really don't have a space for this
this doesn't exist
it's kind of a unique
environment to work with in data
how would you feel if the brooklyn nets
hosted it and he was all about it and
just kind of started running from there
that's great i should probably like
describe what the event is yeah no i was
just going to ask you if we could share
it in there
for people who are are interested in
enjoying it of course yeah i i'm a
little bit in playoff fog i have to
admit um
for those that aren't aware i'm mourning
um my second loss in a row
and i'm a little
this is super off topic but i'm a little
paranoid because i used to work for the
philadelphia 76ers and the second year
that
um
that i was in the playoffs with the
sixers we got swept by the celtics and
so this is my second playoffs with the
nets
and uh
get a little antsy but
different team different parameters
anyway so the women in sports data event
um is going to take place in brooklyn um
in late summer we're going to announce
our official date in 10 days
and it'll be
this event with panels and talks
by women working in sports across the
technical spectrum so
not only analysts and data scientists
but software engineers like me who
partner with our data team
and and turn
those insights into applications for our
invested stakeholders because it's such
a unique environment where
you have a small coaching staff a small
for an office you really want to
get them to interact with the data in a
much more immediate way
than
[Music]
then you might in a traditional
organization where you have like
different
layers to step through
um and so concurrent to our um
our one day event in brooklyn we're
going to be hosting a hackathon
using uh what is looking like event
level player location data from soccer
sponsor to be announced um
and that will take place over about a
six to eight week sprint before
over the summer and we really wanted to
have
something that was supported with
mentors for for women and non-binary
people interested in working with sports
data
to get an idea of what is going to be
most impactful and how do i look at this
data and even if i don't have sports
domain knowledge i have these technical
skills so how do i apply that to
what is genuinely very interesting data
at an abstract level
that's great i just put the link in the
chat too if anyone wants to
check it out as well
but i know there's a lot of data
scientists on the call as well so i
think it would also be
great for us to hear how
you work together with data scientists
on your team as well
productionizing models is a large part
of my job
and i think
traditionally my favorite
part of my job
but
and over the past couple years i've
really been getting into like the very
front of the stack so i've been doing a
lot of data visualization
and so
what sometimes will happen is that a
data scientist will
build a visualization in matplotlib or
gga plot and like doesn't necessarily
want to productionize it in a shiny
dashboard like we need it to be a little
bit more robust it needs to talk with
you know a different database um so i
take that and i turn it into d3 code and
it lives on our brooklynet's application
and it's just a lot more accessible
and and
intuitive for non-data fluent uh users
and the author's query
i'm curious what that transition
looks like or that handoff from the
different teams or how you work together
so i think
everyone is very surprised by how small
our teams are but we're six we're six
people um and we have we're about 50 50
we're three data scientists and three
developers
um
and
really
i wish
i could say that it was very formalized
but because we operate more on on the
basketball calendar than the development
calendar like i have
project manager friends who probably
scream at our process
but often it's kind of like oh like
so-and-so asked me to do this or this is
our
development plan
do you have time in your schedule to to
turn it into something a bit more robust
i realize that wasn't very nice of us to
do this in the middle of playoffs for
you
but thank you for joining us
um step by step maybe it'll turn from
the corner
yes
although i can't say that i'm in boston
but
sup i see you asked a question in the
chat if you want to jump in
yeah sure hi teagan um nice to meet you
thanks for taking the time to speak with
everybody um
i'm i'm a little bit more on the
software side as well that's at least my
kind of background so i'm always curious
as to how every team kind of
you know in this case very literally
team but uh however
what they use in terms of their software
and then kind of data infrastructure uh
if you don't mind speaking to that if
you can
so like i said
we tend to be very secretive
um even down to the stack um which i've
always found kind of strange i i had a
mentor
who who told me a story about how
someone from the clippers had had called
him and was interrogating like what's
the stack like what do you guys use like
are you on snowflake what do you think
of whatever
and uh
and my mentor was like yeah i just like
told him like all of this and
and and the person was uh like oh this
is like really great stuff and it was
just like you know like typical stuff
like
uh
this is our data warehouse this is like
the
the framework that we use like this is
our back end
i think i'll get in trouble if i
disclose the net stack um but
usually
in job ads for
for data engineers or software
developers
i've noticed that teams
are tending to disclose that
so sorry for a non-answer no no no i
respect that i appreciate it highly
competitive environment i get it
i know that was um
tegan that also came up in building the
community as well and you mentioned now
like
a lot of times like you can't talk to
other teams but during covet that was
also really hard
and especially for women in sports data
too
i was wondering if you could talk to
that a little bit
yeah
so when i started in sports
i was pretty much explicitly told like
don't talk to people on other teams like
don't disclose what you're working on
every single thing that you do is a
competitive advantage and on the
technical side like
that's some somewhat true because
different teams have different
investments and different capacities for
investments and
and um
how how they're able to to use data so
for example example when i was the
sixers
um i was also on a very large team but
um there are teams
in the nba that might have maybe only
one or two people that are basically
data unicorns and i'm sure very very
tired
so my experience in sports has only been
to specialize but i didn't really know
the landscape then
and as
as i got further in my career
i noticed that
one of the advantages that the my male
coworkers both in
research and development as well as
basketball operations
had was
they knew people on other teams
and
[Music]
once covid hit
you know i kind of realized oh my god
like
i'm all alone and i was very fortunate
in the sixers that that i worked with
an amazing data scientist savannah sarah
she's now with overtime elite running
their research
and
i just kind of felt like
i really wouldn't want anyone
to feel like an island to feel like they
were alone and because women especially
on sports teams and with a dative
background like it
already tech is so male dominated and
then to intersect that with sport
it's hard right like you have such
unique experiences and of course like
you're not gonna say like oh we're
preparing for your team like this or
we're targeting you know this player
but you can talk about some of the more
mundane things that happen when working
for a sports team
and also some of the more serious
things that happen so
about a year ago i started a slack
community for women working in
basketball specifically
to just kind of get to know each other
um
and
it just blossomed into this amazing
community so supportive um
like we've been on slack all today
uh
but yeah it was kind of that and
that first seed and then diana one of my
co-organizers and i
got to talking of like how can we
how can we how can we grow this why
didn't we have this before
uh how can we make sure that you know
the next woman that that works for a
team and doesn't have
um
like not not only
another woman in her department but
another woman like in the entirety of
basketball
and it was also something that i really
felt compelled to do
when i joined the nests
um
i'm the only woman in the front office
here um and i'm one of the only women in
a front office in the entirety of the
mba and to me like that's that's
literally insane because
data and software skills like that
should be one of the more equitable ways
to enter into sports and it's such a
high visibility high cultural impact
role i mean like you look at my former
boss derral mori or um questions who's
the new gm of the minnesota vikings and
they both have technical roles and this
is kind of
a pathway to build the resume and the
experience of
of being
in sports and getting to the very very
top of leadership
uh
and there's also kind of a
dialogue um on the coaching side of like
how come when are we going to see the
first female mba head coach
and there's usually like one or two
names or commonly cited of like who's
that going to be and yet the number of
assistant coaches who are women has
remained stagnant and
i think it's less than 10 now it's not
very high
it's impressive that um
so quickly you've grown this community
as well
it's a small configuration well the
symposium itself i've seen a lot of
interest on it
but um
i see zach you had asked a question
around some of the data competitions do
you want to jump in
yeah
so
i
uh i'm more an nfl fan uh i know there's
big the big data as i'm sure you've
heard of which is the nfl's open source
data community where they give up like
gps data
uh it helps like
give access to more people to show off
their skills
is there stuff in like that in the mba
because i'm assuming that's one of the
big things i'm helping
uh show off more diversity and now
people more people access this
information because of course
traditional hsp whoever's in the teams
have access to this data
and of course to vast intensity
the same people which isn't really
diverse
and et cetera right and it's very
expensive too
i know so our main data provider right
now is a company called second spectrum
uh
and i know that there are some people in
the media who have subscriptions but
really you need to have
it it's minimum five five to six figures
just for access
so
typically
that type of data is not open source i
i'm not sure if older data sets from
from second spectrum or the previous
company um sport view
are are available and that's really just
more from like my privilege of having
um a different bank account responsible
for for paying for
for that api um
but um
the mba used to hold
a data competition before pre-covet and
i really hope they do it again but this
is kind of the goal of the women in
sports data hackathon is to
to get different providers to to donate
that um
that tracking data or or at least event
level player location data and i'm being
very corey about this because we haven't
officially signed
um our contract for that
but yeah like these these rich data sets
that that show like where are what are
where are players you know what events
are associated with an action uh and how
do you build a model on top of that uh
and also critically i think for
the uh nfl big data poll is that there's
a very large prize associated with it so
it's very motivating to to dig in it's
freely available on kaggle
um but you also you know like okay like
i'm doing this work it's definitely
going to be valuable either for a team
or league
how do i make sure i'm not exploited for
it
thank you
thank you be very interesting to see
i see mike you asked a question as well
um around managing requests would you
want to jump in
yeah apologies taken this is this is
something you kind of ended a sentence
with
about 10 minutes ago but i think the
diversity question is is possibly
uh you know a better one um but
it was something you said about
prioritizing
work and prioritizing requests for your
time
um
and this is something that i'm wrestling
with at the minute
you know people come to your door and
knock and say hey can you do this for me
and you've got to kind of weigh up well
look how long is that going to take is
this something that's
you know an afternoon or a week or
longer
and
can you talk any any about
the difference between
um okay this is just a quick amount of
time so i can i can get this done in an
hour or in an afternoon and then we're
done
versus things that are
like strategic
where you might think this may not be a
high priority but if i get an answer to
this it will unlock
a bunch of other stuff
so how you know how do you what are the
what's the identifiers for you know
quick versus strategic
it's
it's so tricky because i feel like
working in sports we have multiple
full-time jobs right so
my full-time role is being a software
engineer
and then i have another full-time role
of being a front office person so you
know i have to understand my domain of
you know having an opinion on on
basketball in the league and
and upcoming games
[Music]
so i don't think that this is a solved
problem by by any means
with
my team or
or around the league
uh
but i've been talking to a lot of um
[Music]
project managers like how
exactly like how do i solve this
question because we don't have enough
room to you know appoint you know like a
scrum master or like
a guard dog essentially to say like no
like i protect my engineers time like
let them do their thing and and
something that's kind of wild right now
so this is not actually my office
my office isn't something we call very
cutely the war room i think it's like
very common in sports to call it the war
room and i have strong opinions on this
but
because it's kind of the the node of
of where our organization lives it's
great because you know people there's
not a wall between r d and the rest of
basketball operations but then like
you'll have 20 guys gathering around and
like watching film or like talking to
the scouts and so it's like how do you
sit down and say like i have like this
really difficult problem that like i
have to like enter the matrix to solve
and
if they're a different if there's
various like fires around me then it's
not going to get solved
until it's too late
so
i've been
trying to kind of put on like what's my
what's my product my project manager hat
like we do you know stand-ups um on a
weekly level and
you know coordinate um
all of our um
our processes through through github
but as far as like determining at a high
level
what
what's an emergency
versus like what's our long-term
research prerogative and then something
also that's very important to me um is
making sure that everybody on our team
has room to learn and that that time is
protected you know that concept of 20
time where like i can't really
explain or sell to
um say like my gm like we're gonna
invest a lot of time on you know working
on computer vision
um
it may or may not work
uh and you're not gonna see like a
direct outcome of that project but if it
does then it's gonna be extremely
valuable and it's gonna be a significant
advantage but like i can't promise that
so i try to protect like that 20 time of
just like this is just like learning
this is just personal development this
is experimental and like yes it will
it you know projects that that we come
up with and experiments that that we do
are kind of
geared towards understanding the game of
basketball better and to gain a
competitive edge but are a little bit
more closely aligned with you know that
technical
um maintenance um
so so that's about like one day a week
and it's a little bit more flexible
during our off-site off-season
post-draft in the summer before training
camp
um
and then we kind of have to balance like
most of my team has been in basketball
for for for many years
uh so we can kind of anticipate like
what the cadence of the season like what
are the kind of questions can we either
like anticipate and build out like what
is
like okay like
we didn't crash the glass
well enough like
we we know like what the question is
going to be
the next day and so like we have
resources of here's the study that we
did a year ago
on this question here we've applied new
data to it now
um
this is what we might recommend or this
is what we would look into
and then like the one-off requests
um
[Music]
we try to be pretty like on top of that
depending on who's asking and i think
like that comes more from
um
organizational structure and having
strong leadership
from the top and like a lot of buy-in
which i feel very very fortunate to have
um
but also approachability is is really
important so i would like i wouldn't
want
uh our department to feel inaccessible
or anybody in our department to feel
inaccessible even to
um like the the new grad
basketball operations assistant um
frequently we've we've we've gotten
questions of like oh i'm really
interested in what you're doing it can
even be like super
um
super beginner like
how do i
um
like i have this question with
x domain like how would i start to learn
r or like can you show me how to
um
query the database like what does that
look like and so we try to build tools
to empower um
different levels of
of users both from their role but also
their comfort with technology and to
make sure that there's not this this
hard line between r d and basketball
and then there's something um the former
director of um
of r d for the milwaukee bucks um
recently told me he's like i don't have
a tech job i have a basketball job
and i thought how i've never really
thought i've thought it more like i have
a tech job in in a basketball team
uh
and i think that's really more like a
difference of philosophy of like how do
you protect that and also how do you
make sure
that that's a goal right like the goal
in invis in basketball is the same as as
any other business which is
to succeed like it's just a little bit
more literal for us like to win
i really like that idea of protecting
the 20 of
your team's time
and i know that can be so hard sometimes
too so how
how do you actually go about doing that
in practice
um
personally
um
i try to make sure that i have like
literally like 20 of my time um during
the week vlogged on some other like
research or development initiative that
i'm interested in
um it's very difficult to do during the
season because we play games on weekends
we play games late at night and it's
almost
it feels a little unreasonable to say
this is a nine to five job but also you
need to show up at the arena at 6 30
or go straight from practice facility to
the arena and
and show up the next morning um so we're
pretty
pretty relaxed on like
you're responsible for for managing
how you want to see your time and like
there are only like true like real
emergencies and they're not going to
come from our department
thank you
i see there's a few anonymous questions
coming in too and one was
how do you see sports analytics evolve
over the long term
is it more proprietary advanced
algorithms or more proprietary data or
something else
so
there's this book called the mvp machine
and it's about player development in
baseball
and i think that the biggest advances in
sports analytics are going to be
moving in in that
um that direction and like how do you
empower
your quote-unquote end users your
players or or even your front office
to
to grow
um using using database insights
i think that
in basketball because we are
relatively small compared to a data team
for say baseball which will have
you know departments in the dozens
um like like a true startup um
that we will probably remain
um
more of like the the interlocutors
and
some teams who are interested in like
building out
um more models or taking on um
new um experimental technical projects
uh i think that'll be more of a team
prerogative rather than a trend um and
like that advantage is gonna be the same
advantage um
that that any team has in in fielding
filling personnel right like it's how
much money do you have to spend
um
but i i do think that
that vendors and and like
the ability to
not necessarily deliver
modeling and insights to a team
but
doing a lot of the processing power that
would be expensive for us
and
taking care of
the sort of things that
maybe a general manager doesn't um like
can't see the the immediate impact so
like my example of like i would love for
my 20 time project to be working on
computer vision projects um but is that
uh if if there were a ven vendor that
could um provide that
that might be a more efficient
use of of both our our time and
resources
thank you
i see there are quite a few other
questions in the chat too and um bala
you had a question around data privacy
would you want to jump in
uh yeah
so
i
i just want to
understand how you keep tab
on various data regulations
especially i'm sure us has each state
has their own regulation so
how do you manage the metadata how do
you share models or
because it's data is key for everything
right i mean that's all proprietary and
in-house i'm not sure
um how you mean
so so
the data basically would be associated
with a player
or a team so team might be
all right because it's a rolled up
heuristic data which is fine right but
if it is with the player
then you might need to
in your europe we have gdpr so we have
to be compliant and there are different
data policies that we need to
go through to use that data
i i'm not
aware how it is done in u.s so that's
that's where my curiosity came
sure
so
the nba players association has very
strict regulations for
um
how and what kind of data
we can collect
so
the inferences that we make from the
data sets that we subscribe to or
collect ourselves like that that is
that's totally fine
um
but
for instance like you can't put a a
tracking chip in in a ball you can't
have a player
wear wearables um in game like they have
to give consent to do that and then only
um within a particular context
um
and so because you know we're really
only dealing with um
20 some um
including
rg league players
um a pretty like limited
set of
of players
but uh have you thought through
when it comes to scale
maybe five or ten years down the line
uh again this question might be of
relevance right because right now you're
talking about a very small data set
which could be easily managed
but
if if you're thinking about like five
years down the line getting all the
players data
and systematically capturing it rather
than you know
someone manually entering it
all these things would come into play
right or
you're not thought your your team has
not thought through that state
well
i think that we're talking about
a couple different
sources for data
um
and
yeah like i'm struggling with this
because i i'm definitely in my my team
brain right now um
so it's really like not a question of
going to scale because you know we
we work at the s
at the service
of these players of these teams and like
we wouldn't be able to to productionize
or build a product that you know went
public
i see um
in terms of this data
and the kinds of data that you use
frank just had a question in the chat as
well
uh frank do you want to jump in
i see tatsu
his love for this as well
yeah so it's directly related here um
all the on-court stuff makes a ton of
sense to me like that's that's pretty
clear
um
i'm i'm always super interested in the
player behaviors or like really anyone's
consumer behaviors player behaviors and
as we get more data there right like i
actually don't have my loop on today but
right like if i'm wearing my whoop i can
help
to a certain extent right there's some
inaccuracies in the data and their
models as well
like i can start to make better
decisions about right should i take
should i go easier on my run today
should i go harder and i'm wondering
like do you guys do you and your team
support
some of that stuff
and then it makes me wonder like how
it's it's cool but then like how real
time can you get with that regular can
you make different decisions right
before the game starts to say like hey
this player right like look at their
data they're telling me they're fine but
if i'm the coach like i want to make a
different decision about
playtime start
lineup i don't know how
those things get
we have like a very robust um and
excellent player performance staff that
that does address like more of the like
physiological and athletic um question
like that that data um
but you know i was saying like a lot of
this requires player consent and like
player
um
willingness to opt in because you can't
just say like
well like take the the example of sleep
like sleep is such a huge concern um
in in the nba because we play 82 regular
season games and so the travel distance
like if you're playing games
every other night or back to back and
you're flying from new york to san
francisco to san antonio
that is such a huge drain on
on your ability to perform at an elite
level how do you monitor like okay like
maybe you're not gonna um maybe you need
to rest or or maybe um you shouldn't
play
um
at
you know at a extremely hard level um
during practice um things like that
um
and i think that
um two previous questions point of like
what's the next direction in sports
analytics um it is this kind of like
behavioral question of like one how do
you get players to opt in
um
personally i think that it has to be
like it can't be surveillance analytics
it has to be
what do i like what am i going to get
out of this and what do i want the team
to know and it becomes kind of tricky
because like you want to optimize as a
player um
how am i going to perform right
but you also need to be very careful of
exposing
um like certain data to your team
because it can affect where
um
you know
how much your next contract might be or
you if they know something about you
know an injury i have are they gonna try
and trade me
like how much leverage do i i have
got it yeah the the
and those trade-offs make sense
i like that
idea of framing it that was what am i
going to get out of it like thinking of
how we can all use that
even not with like players but business
stakeholders as well
um i see there were a lot of other
questions earlier mark you had a
question about um
like when you need to hire another
full-time person do you want to jump in
and
and add some context there
sorry i was on mute yeah um i know you
mentioned you have like a super or a
pretty small team
um and this is tangentially related to
mike's question about balancing
priorities
i guess when do you
like what's the cutoff between we have
um all these different priorities and
some of them we can push back
um
and some of them you know we'll just
communicate that these are
are lesser versus
hey we need to accomplish all this stuff
and we need to
either expand the team or you know
offload something to a different team
we we always need at least one extra
person i think
both on the engineering side and out of
the data side
um
but a model i think that is
maybe more successful for for us
is we we almost have uh
technical translators embedded um in
certain departments within basketball so
we have a director of coaching analytics
who's the main liaison um with the
coaching staff and he sits on on the
bench
at every game and provides in-game
analysis but he also does
um you know modeling specifically
related to to um
game play uh and i i think a reasonable
question is like should that be one role
should it be you know
distinct roles how do you
how do you um
kind of
merge a team if it were distinct um
and then like what about departments
that don't have
um that embedded technical person so
like our cap and strategy group is two
people but when i was in philadelphia
cap and strategy was
um technically part of my department we
were officially when i started before we
we
converted to
research and development we were
strategy and analytics
and so
yeah
it's always tough because
we're very lean and it's almost like
there are too many hats for
for one head
um
but
at the end of the day like you're you're
essentially a consulting group embedded
with a team
and
you have to respond to that more so than
you know technical prerogatives that
that you might have with as a team and
kind of negotiate like
i think that the payoff if we invest
in
in this research direction or if we
build out this
tool then
then we'll save both our time as well as
as our stakeholders time so
not a satisfying answer i think
but
that's because i don't think
yeah i don't think that it's solved
anywhere and it's maybe not solved even
by more people my my group in
philadelphia
we used to claim that we were 10
but that also included
outside consultants who worked in
academia and at google brain
and
you know the work that our consultants
did
certainly dovetailed with uh
the work that that we did but it wasn't
um
they're kind of insulated from
the demands that um those of us who are
directly embedded with the team and have
front office roles or coaching roles um
would have to support
so i don't know if maybe that's a better
model or you know maybe
rather than directly con you know
contracting with consultants you you
sign an exclusive contract with some
kind of vendor or
or um
even outsourced development i'm not sure
i think everybody it it's it's more
budget constrained than than
optimized
yeah someone from the chat vibes and i
definitely agree with that
i see there is also an anonymous
question earlier
around how much variation is there in
the levels of data sophistication
between different teams
hmm
i don't want to get in trouble
or i guess it could be across different
sports too
yeah
i think you can kind of tell
based on public titles which is maybe a
funny thing for me to say because the
nets are one of the few teams that don't
have a public directory of their
analytics staff
um but i know that um my friend sarah
gallis who's director of r d for houston
astros does have a fairly large team
that is um
amazingly like fairly equitable um
so go sarah um
but
yeah like
she employs like for instance an ml
engineer and you know if we had like one
person to be like explicitly an ll
engineer that would be incredible
um
i've always wanted um as i've mentioned
a couple times on this chat i really
really really love a project manager
somebody who's like explicitly is to to
keep us all in line um and to
to serve kind of as
um that that guard dog of time but i'd
also kind of love a designer like to
like really go like full
full stack
well thank you
um on that topic kind of like of the
variation between different teams i see
chris you asked the question around like
reaching out to other sports
organizations
if you're on do you want to jump in or
chris maybe he had to jump at the half
hour mark but the question was are you
still able to reach out to other
professional sport organizations to
share data concepts like u.s olympic
teams or ufc for example
yeah we've definitely done some
um
both data conversations of like
how would you
approach this problem in football how
would you approach this problem in
soccer and you know there are certain
analogies in sport that that do carry
over
i think
it depends on on the comfort
it's it's really not rnd's call of how
much you can can share and it's probably
going to be more the prerogative of an
owner
a general manager
um so
fortunately here at brooklyn we've been
pretty into having conversations with
with other pro teams outside of
basketball to kind of
get do a temperature check on like what
are your processes like at a fairly high
level but also like
even down to like the nitty gritty of
data management and
how do how do you manage this with six
people how do you manage this with 12
people on your team what would you do if
you had like that extra
engineer
um
but yeah we don't we we definitely don't
talk to basketball teams but
there are
there's certain analogs i think it in
the types of
actions that that happen in basketball
or even like the structure of the
leagues that
that are certainly parsable to
you know like
fifa or
hockey
and another
another advantage would be like if your
ownership group
um has a multi-sport portfolio
so if your ownership group owns like a
hockey team or soccer team then you're
probably going to be doing some data
sharing there
um when i was on the six areas
our ownership group owned the new jersey
devils and so
in my contract it literally said i could
be seconded to the news near juicy
devils
in spite of not knowing anything about
hockey that you know that that high
level like how do you how do you build
out an application that's
you know
intelligible is interactive is
um
easily digestible by somebody who is
sport fluent but not necessarily
data fluent and you know like there are
certain touch points within com
competitive sport like the prerogative
across four is how do you win
and there are
um decision points like a game or a
draft or or free agency like that that
seems to be almost like fairly universal
of
how do you how do you um prepare for
those instances and like what are the
best strategies
it's interesting walking this fine line
of like what is secretive or what can be
shared and i know that's with every
industry too like with pharmaceutical
industries i know they do a lot of open
sharing and a lot of presentations and
conferences with each other but i'm sure
there's a ton of stuff that they don't
want to share with each other too
um
i know steve you just asked a question
in the chat if you want to jump in
hey there yeah
so interesting chat i'm trying to
get opposite a little bit more details
which is how do you
how are you supported
as software engineers
is there something to self-support
yourself do you have uh
since this happens or are you using
third parties to actually do your
administration
how do you look after yourselves
oh great question are we doing a good
job of that i don't know it's playoff
season
um we're very fortunate that that we do
have someone on our team who does take
ownership of that
that role um
[Music]
for other teams
um
every option that you've listed um
it certainly could be
um the direction that they choose
uh so it really kind of depends on
do you have enough resources to support
somebody who would be internal or
um do you have enough like time
resources to self-support or
do you have enough um financial
resources where like you could outsource
it and you can allow your team to focus
more on on the development and
you know data pipelining and
the immediate
requests that your team stakeholders may
have so what proportion would you say if
you're if you're
assuming
your group which is doing your sounds
like you're doing self-support what
percentage of time do you find is
doing the data analysis and what type is
time itself spent
building servers or configuring servers
to build for you to use
it's pretty rule specific um so like i
said that we have we're very fortunate
to have one person on our team
who
spends the majority of their time
um in that role
um
but you know because we're so small we
have to be empowered to handle it on our
own
okay thank you
thank you
and there was an anonymous question
as well and i'm going to guess what one
of the acronyms is but how competitive
is it to get front office get into front
office data science or software
engineering roles for a sports team
um
very
people say that it's very competitive
but i think that it ends up being very
lucky
and
yeah as i was talking about earlier
it's supposed to be one of the more
equitable ways to get into a front
office or to work for a team
because you're supposed to be evaluated
on your skill set
um
and not whether you've played
professionally before i certainly
haven't played in the nba before i've
never played basketball even at a you
know highly competitive level um
i think that there are kind of like some
secret tricks that that people
on the inside
know
um
and
everyone usually says
that you have to build a
portfolio
with basketball
related projects
you should have
um
kind of
an intuitive sense of what might be
useful for communicating data to a coach
or
or to
um to a front office within a specific
domain like salary cap or scouting
but i you know i personally didn't have
a basketball portfolio um
i didn't
even
really think
oh like i i have to work in in
basketball
um
so i think that like my experience is
probably
different and and maybe unique um
[Music]
it's very difficult
to get
a role um
for a front office because they just
don't come up that often
and when people are hiring i think it's
kind of like the greater trend in the
data science and software engineering
industries now where everyone would love
a senior developer or a senior data
scientist but nobody wants to hire
um
an entry level um person and then how do
you get an entry-level job if that job's
not advertised then it's
what's your network and it's a lot
easier to build your network if you're
already associated with basketball
or you have a lot of time to work on
um projects
in a visible way for free and i think
that that that kind of shadow
requirement is specifically
disadvantaging women and and um people
of color because we have different
responsibilities we have different
demands on our time
and
um oftentimes we haven't been told that
you know that's
one of the blueprints
um
to get a job in sports and i just think
that
we as an industry need to be doing a
better job of
making sure that
like that requirement
if it has to be a requirement
that we provide
kind of a development pathway that's
rewarded either through a hackathon the
nba used to have one
or for women in sports data which will
have cash prizes but to specifically
target and develop those communities
to
to mentor them and
you know tell them specifically this is
this is what we want in basketball this
is what we want in football
but i don't know because
teams are not going to grow
in in any significant sense you know
if you have an r d department that's
larger than the rest of basketball
operations then
um the people who keep the books are
going to be like well why don't we just
hire an outside organization to do this
that you know sells the same information
or does the same thing like they're not
going to understand
the the business case
for a large department so i don't think
that that positions it's not going to be
a growth industry um but you can use
those same skill sets to get a job for
a second spectrum or for a hawkeye
or
[Music]
even in like traditional big tech that
would love to
provide services for for sports so for
instance
um zach he brought up big data ball like
that's sponsored by aws a hundred
thousand dollars and they are the you
know named data provider and so i think
there's always going to be
that that pathway
that
will make people attractive to sports
but this is not really
um
kind of a direct
blueprint for doing it
thank
you i am
i see there were a lot of questions we
unfortunately didn't get to within the
hour so if people are on and want to
jump in and ask their question feel free
to just raise your hand right now too if
there's anything that i missed
um trevor i i see you had asked one
um around measuring
when you're making a difference do you
want to jump in
yeah hi everyone
so
that's always my my constant question
right so clearly
when you're doing a project you're
always asking yourself you know am i
making a difference or am i going to
measure success
right and clear it's i mean it's evident
that more organizations
even here in jamaica
actually getting more data science
departments
hiring more analysts it makes sense
right
but how do we justify our existence
qualitatively and quantitatively so in a
sport like basketball that i like as
well
is how do you know that you're making a
difference in terms of the bottom line
at the end of the day if you understand
what i'm asking
totally i think that it's
one of the
the joys and terrors of being in a data
intensive role for a team is that you
can't
point to
oh i
you know we did x or we we recommended y
and
now we have an mba championship but it
really has to be does
does analytics does does data and
investment in data
at a league level
indicate that you're going to have
sustained success
and i think that the investment in
analytics departments
and the success of the teams that have
been able to to do so
is kind of indicative of of how teams
are evaluating the value that that data
provide
um
but i do think that
that that's really nice to say but we
also need to hold ourselves accountable
of like
we're using all this time and resources
does it
does it contribute to winning does it
help
um
make
help us make better decisions
and i think that
it's almost a qualitative assessment of
as certain pressure points
did we create an environment where
it was easier to negotiate a trade or
um
pull the trigger on uh
drafting a certain player over another
or
um even to the level of you know
preparing for what happens on court like
did we
create an environment of all right like
we knew these tendencies tendencies we
could project
this expected value
were we able to support that
in a way that it was actionable and
retainable
and implemented either at a player level
or a coaching level
thank you understand
it's not an easy answer
yeah
thank you i i know we're taking you uh
out of your work during playoffs
do you have time for one more question
sure okay awesome well
thank you so much for all that you do to
open the doors to others to get into the
sports analytics space as well and the
community building that you do
so just wanted to ask
you if you have any tips
for
us who maybe do want maybe want to do
something similar in our own industries
i wouldn't say that i'm a very active or
fluent twitter user but i got some
advice from my friend kathy evans who
is vice president of research and
development for the washington wizards
and also my friend brittany doblinson
who's former assistant coach for the
toronto raptors and data analysts
and both of them are are much much
better at social media than i am um but
they told me you know like you're one of
the only women in a technical role in
the nba and
50 of mba teams are hiring for software
developers and like nobody knows what
that looks like or or that you can even
do that as a job
um and so i thought oh well
it just like through being visible like
that might help
um then i obviously would love to do
that
um and then it just kind of
made everything else as far as the
community building so much easier
because i could see a response and i met
so many people and it was easier to
to develop a connection because i could
reach out to somebody or they could
reach out to me and we could have
something to talk about whether it's
like a thread that they wrote or
um
an invitation to a community
so
yeah at a practical level um
just
just being visible and
um
and making friends
awesome well thank you so much for
jumping on and sharing your experience
with us
really appreciate it and thank you all
for all the great questions too
um if there are some that i'll miss that
i missed i'll send them over to you
teagan if that's okay through email of
course yeah okay thank you for having me
and yeah if you have any questions i'll
do my best to answer them um you can
always
say hi in twitter
um
i will never give you an opinion on a
player because i cannot afford the
tampering fine
but i'll do my best
awesome i'll share your
twitter account right here in the chat
too if people want to go and follow
thank you so much have a great rest of
the day everybody
you